has an initial budget been set out for
the new stargate series and is it a
little disappointing
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so if you are a regular site tracker
you'll know that i have contacts that
work in and around mgm you'll also know
that over the last couple of weeks
there's been big meetings between the
chief executives at mgm and amazon at
mgm's film headquarters in beverly hills
part of those discussions
were centered around stargate as well as
other big projects that planned for the
next couple of years we also know that
brad wright has submitted a pilot script
for a new stargate series we know that
mgm is seriously considering about
pushing forward to the series and that
amazon are really keen for stargate to
return to our screens
so why would the budget already be
planned out
well before they get to the green light
stage there are many people that look at
what the stargate series would
potentially cost they consider things
like
how many episodes does amazon want how
long the episodes would be how many cast
and crew would be required for brad
right's vision to be fulfilled how long
would they have to rent the sound stage
for what are the sort of location costs
for filming a sort of a time frame for
filming how long it would take um as
well as legal and other fees there are
people at mgm that are very good at
estimating these costs they have come up
with a figure now before i tell you how
much they're thinking this show will
cost i have to tell you that these are
initial budgets and their estimates
once the show is green lit all of these
things have sort of gone through again
there would be a script for more
episodes etc and there would be
more far more detailed plans and the
budget would actually be re-estimated
but at the moment they do have a figure
in mind and it does tell us a lot about
how much emphasis amazon is mgm are
putting on this new project because at
the end of the day part of also this
estimation is based on what amazon think
the show is worth to them basically how
much they're willing to pay for the
product before i tell you the actual
figure let's put a little bit of context
in
so the expanse
series a lot of us love
cost around about three and a half
million dollars an episode to produce
between some cost less some cost a bit
more but three and a half million
dollars an episode is roughly the
average
if we look at game of thrones for
example which is a big lavish production
hbo always invested 100 million dollars
a series
even back when it was still a massive
risk and wasn't the big phenomenal
success it became it was a hundred
million dollars a series
towards the end where they did less
episodes per series game of thrones cost
around 15 million dollars an episode to
produce
netflix are currently producing a series
of the last airbender this is again
another series which is a bit of a risk
there was a movie it was a huge flop
there was a cartoon that was actually
pretty cool but produced in the tv
series is a risk for netflix but they're
still willing to invest anything up to
15 million dollars an episode
we think about the lord of the rings now
that is just schoolians that's just
ridiculous amount of money and we
shouldn't compare stargate to that at
all but it does show amazon are willing
to spend on a project if they think it's
worthwhile
so
what sort of things should we be
comparing this budget to for me i think
stargate should be looking at star trek
that should be the goal that should be
from a production value point of view at
least what we're looking to achieve with
stargate so for me again
what star trek spend on per episode it
is relevant to what i would hope they
would spend on stargate if that is what
stargate hopes to aspire to then i would
hope that the budget would be similar
now picard series one and two have
roughly cost nine million dollars an
episode and to be honest disco costs
about the same a little less eight to
eight and a half million dollars an
episode
so for me i would hope that the budget
for a series of target would be in and
around that area
sadly it isn't
at the moment it looks like the
estimation is for around 16 million
dollars for a series that series would
be an estimated 10 or 12 episodes
and that that would basically mean five
to six million dollars per episode now i
actually think for a returning franchise
something that hasn't been on our
screens for
15 years and at the end of the day it's
five times more than brad i got first
time round because stargate sg1's
initial budget was only nine hundred
thousand dollars an episode
also because it's on a streaming service
brad wright does have a lot of
flexibility here he could do a thirteen
episode series if he wanted to if the
story dictated it and he could stretch
the budget a little further or he could
maybe do eight or nine episodes if again
that's what the story needed and he
could spend a lot more on it per episode
once this project is green lit and brad
wright has full control because it's a
streaming service he really does have a
lot more power than when it was back on
a network and it was 22 episodes this is
what we need to fill in our schedule
just do it but as i say i am a little
bit disappointed i would have hoped the
budget would be in and around the 9 to
10 million dollar area so that it could
compete with star trek i would expect
the demographic for the sort of people
that will be watching this show is very
similar to star trek but amazon are
looking at demographics they are looking
at surveys that have been sent out
asking people do you want to watch
stargate they do look at the viewing
figures of stargate and things like
stargate appearing on pluto in the
united states now is a big show of that
how much people actually want to watch
the show
amazon will take all those figures they
will do lots of graphs i imagine and
they will figure out what they think the
product is worth
this is only the first series and it's
only the first run of the series so 10
or 12 episodes that doesn't necessarily
mean that would be the full series it
might just be what amazon are willing to
buy initially
so we could see potentially more
episodes than that in the first series
or we could see similarly to star wars
two or three different series running
alongside each other per year so even
though we only might get a 10 or 12
episode run we're actually might get
into up to 30 episodes per year the
flexibility of stargate appearing on a
stream and service i think is actually a
really positive thing and i think we'll
produce a far more interesting tv show
in the end the one thing though i would
say is that until a project is green lit
this is these are all just estimates i
remember a story about gene roddenberry
and star trek the next generation he
realized that
the budget basically wasn't going to
allow them to build a set for
engineering engineering didn't appear in
the initial pilot anywhere so he was
fearful that if the engineering didn't
get built in the initial stages of
production that it never would be
because the budget would never allow it
so he immediately went back rewrote the
pilot and wrote in a scene that required
engineering
he got his set
and that is
a big point to make with a lot of these
tv shows that a lot of the expense comes
from the initial setup a lot of the
expense comes from building the initial
set sets that they're going to use day
in day out so if brad wright is smart
and and
at the end of the day we know he is
he could actually get a lot more bang
for his book
we know that he did sg1 for example on a
very small budget and really got great
production value for it
we also know that stargate isn't
necessarily as cgi driven as star trek
there might not be as many virtual sets
and off-world sets and things also you
know you can run around a quarry and
make it look very alien brad wright's an
expert to that
stargate is more grounded in reality and
therefore the actual initial cost of
setting up the show might not be as much
as star trek so we might actually get
just as good production value
and say we like about star trek it's a
beautifully made show
it might not be a particularly
entertaining show or well written or
makes sense at times but
it is a beautifully produced show
if we want to get that sort of
production value we might actually be
able to get it for a much lower cost and
maybe that explains why these valuations
of what the series would cost and the
the initial budgets
is significantly lower than what star
trek costs
so
please get in the comments and tell me
what you think do you think these
initial budgets are
fair do you think they're a reasonable
expectation of what a show like stargate
coming back for the first time would
expect to see
and you know series 2 series 3 series 4
might have much bigger budgets if the
show's successful
or do you think this is a concern do you
think that a lot of the rumors have been
coming out about amazon thinking that
stargate is the sleeping giant of sci-fi
and a show that they desperately want
back on screens as quickly as possible
maybe isn't being fulfilled at the
moment and maybe mgm and amazon aren't
as behind the show as we thought
get in the comments tell me exactly what
you think and if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe hit the
bell notification it really helps us out
also consider becoming a fully fledged
site tracker hit the join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you